[Music]
one design flaw that I see in a lot of
apps is having a delete button with no
option to undo or to confirm the
deletion first you could implement an
undo button but then you have some
complex state management issues to worry
about or you could trigger an alert
message but that's kind of annoying for
your users what I want to show you today
is how to build a hold to delete button
which i think is a refreshing take on
how to prevent accidental deletion and
it's a great exercise for learning how
to work with rxjs and angular directives
if you're new to the channel I can
subscribe and you can find the full
source code on angular firebase comm the
inspiration for this video comes from
Josh on our slack team who asked for a
more elegant way to handle deletions
than just showing a standard bootstrap
confirm modal I'm definitely not the
first person to come up with this idea
there's a number of apps that have
started using this functionality instead
of alert messages or undo buttons and
the idea is pretty simple we have a
regular delete button but the user needs
to hold it for a certain amount of time
before the actual deletion is executed
the way this works is we have an angular
directive that can attach itself to any
Dom element or other component then
track the time difference between the
mousedown event and the mouse up event
then we can emit a custom event every
tenth of a second so we can update our
progress bar while the user is holding
the button down I'm just in a regular
angular app and I have angular fire
installed just so we have something
meaningful to delete in an actual
database but this lesson is primarily
focused on rxjs and angular the first
thing we'll do is generate our directive
by running ng generate directive
holdable from the command line we'll be
able to attach this directive to a
button and then keep track of gits
internal state and then emit events up
to the parent component to do that will
import host listener event emitter and
output from angular core we'll also
bring in a few things from rxjs that
we'll see here in a minute the first
thing we'll do is set up a custom event
and this is the data that we want to
emit up to the parent component this
event will emit the number of
milliseconds that a user has held the
button down so that allows the parent
component to decide how long the user
can hold the button before it fires off
the delete operation to fire store in
angular you can create public custom
events by using the output deck
and making the value in event emitter in
our case we'll just be omitting the
number of milliseconds and then if we
look at the HTML it would be used like
this we insert the holdable directive in
a button and then we wrap hold time in
parentheses because it's an event and
later in the video we'll define a
function that handles that event let's
go back to our directive and the next
thing we'll define is the internal state
of this component we can define it as a
subject which itself is just an
observable that we can push values to
and there are two possible states that
this directive can be in either the user
is holding the button down or they're
not the next thing I'll do is define an
observable called cancel which will be
based off of the states or subject
eventually we'll set this observable up
to only emit values when the user stops
holding the button but before we can do
that we need to first listen to Mouse
events on this element and then update
the internal state so there are two ways
that a user can cancel holding the
button they can either stop clicking or
they can move the mouse outside of the
button area we use host listener to
listen to events like Mouse up that are
built into the Dom and if we want to
listen to multiple events we can just
stack them on top of each other like
this then we can write a single method
to run the same code when either event
occurs when the user stops holding the
button we just want to update the
internal state on this directive to be
canceled this is important because will
actually react to the state change when
we keep track of the amount of time that
the user has been holding down the next
step is to add a host listener for the
mouse down event and the first thing I'm
going to do here is add a console log
that will console.log that the hold is
started and bright-green and just a
quick side tip you can console.log with
custom CSS by doing % c on the first
argument and make the second argument
the actual Styles you want applied there
the next thing I'll do is update the
internal state to start so we know the
user has started a new hold then I'll
define a number that defines the
interval period so this will be every
tenth of a second or 100 milliseconds
you can adjust that as needed and then
I'll set up an or XJS interval with that
number when we subscribe to this
interval it will emit a number that
increases by one every tenth of a second
0 1 2 3 etc now the tricky part is that
we want this observable to stop emitting
values when the user has stopped holding
it and for that we can
actually use the take and tell operator
from rxjs then passing that canceled
observable so when canceled emits it
will cause this observable interval to
complete but while the interval is
running we want to use the tap operator
to emit the custom event which is hold
time omit and then we'll omit the number
of milliseconds by multiplying it again
by that original interval number so that
will emit the number of milliseconds
when the user clicks down but it will
keep running forever because right now
we don't have any observable that will
cancel it we can create that observable
by taking our source state subject and
then piping in the filter operator and
filter it so that only that cancel
events are emitted and then we'll also
throw in a tap operator here and
console.log that the hold is stopped and
bright-red
and then we'll have our custom event you
met the number 0 just so we can restart
our progress bar when we get to the
component that takes care of the
directive code we can now go into the
HTML and just drop that into a button
and we'll get all of that custom
functionality if we click the button and
hold for a second you'll see that we
first get our green console log then we
get a few hundred milliseconds and then
it stops and emits it'll be the
responsibility of the parent component
to listen to these events and then we'll
set our demo up to delete the document
from fire store once it's been held for
at least one second we can go ahead and
start in the HTML will add the holdable
directive and then listen to our custom
hold time event and then we'll define a
function here called hold handler that
takes the event as its argument if you
want to see how many milliseconds the
button has been held you can just add a
console log to the hold handler function
then to make this non-trivial we'll
bring in firestore and load a collection
of documents now I'm just going to copy
and paste a pretty big chunk of code
here but basically what I'm doing is I'm
grabbing a collection from fire store
and then I'm mapping the document IDs to
that collections data payload so we can
use that idea to later delete a document
I cover this code in detail in the full
ionic course as well as multiple other
videos in the past it's not critical for
this video so we'll just brush past it
the next important thing that we'll do
is generate a component called customer
which will hold the data for each
document and fire store when we retrieve
this collection from fire store we're
going to loop over it with ng
four and then we'll pass each unwrapped
object to the child component the app
component is the parent component so
we'll set up our loop there we declared
the app customer component run the ng
for loop angularfire gives us that as an
observable so we unwrap it with the
async pipe then we'll pass each document
object down to the child component by
wrapping customer and square brackets
and we'll set up that custom input
property in the component in the next
step now before we write the child
component there's one last tip that I
want to show you and that's if you are
using a progress bar you'll want to add
an animation property in the CSS
otherwise it will look really janky as
it animates from step to step now the
child components going to be pretty
simple we first bring in angular
firestore as well as input from angular
core then we'll decorate the customer
property with input which allows it to
be passed in through the parent
component and we'll also set up a
progress property that starts at zero
now the most important aspect of this
component is the delete customer method
that handles the whole time event that
we defined from our directive this
method will take the event itself as
well as the customer object as an
argument and it will update the progress
on this component so we can change the
value of the progress bar when the
buttons being held down it's going to
emit this event every tenth of a second
we're dividing it by ten to treat it
more like a zero to 100 percentage and
if that value is greater than 100 or one
second in this case we'll use angular
firestore to delete that customers
document from the database and then the
last formality for this demo is just the
HTML markup in that child component so
we'll just interpolate some values from
the database then we'll add our button
down here at the bottom which of course
uses the holdable directive then uses
the delete customer method as the event
handler and then we also have that
progress property available on this
component which we can use to show a
progress bar the only trick we have to
do here is add value in square brackets
so it uses the progress value that we
define in the component and now if we go
back to our app we should have a result
that looks something like this
I have some dummy records in my database
if I click the delete button it will
start the progress bar but if I let go
then it stops if I keep holding it for
at least one second then you'll see it
actually deletes the record from the
firestore database
hopefully that gives you some ideas on
how to handle deletes gracefully in your
UI I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there if you have any questions send me
a message on slack and if you're ready
to build and ship a real life product
consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase comm you'll get access
to all kinds of exclusive content like
my full courses and book as well as one
on one project support thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you soon